you've got like
good critical response to your music
yeah yeah so you know i'm working on my
next album
um which is coming out this year and
well i'd say mid
maybe july may just around that time
summer
and uh yeah man like i obviously i
released an album last year at the
simulation and it did bit
um but this year man i've gone even
like bigger with the people i've got
featuring
you know the production is just even
more big and it's just
it's just such it's just a way better
album than last
last year and uh you know i've really
had time to focus
on my craft work on my flows work on
my singing work and work on my rapping
and
just essentially making the body of what
i'm really
really excited for people to hear and
you know i felt like
the simulation was a nice a nice thing
to just dip my toes in and you know into
the whole
album space and you know i realized what
i
did what i did good and what i did bad
in and i was like okay cool
let me continue the good and let me work
on the bad and that's essentially what
i've done with this next album and
man like obviously i released a track
with craig david
um released another track this uh this
year with uh anne marie
uh it's out next week friday and um
okay that's the day after this [ __ ]
drops yeah so tomorrow
beautiful yeah [ __ ] interesting so i
had tomorrow
[ __ ] there we go anne-marie and uh
you know i've got other big features
coming through and
yeah i've got some big songs on my own
as well so it's it's
really exciting and i feel like this is
the part
this is the point where i really get to
showcase how well i'm doing with music
and i don't want to be seen as just
you know a youtuber doing uh
music you know i i want people to see me
as an artist
you know i'm an artist i'm a youtuber
i'm a boxer i'm all these things
and you know i don't want people to take
anything away just because i have
a large fan base so yeah now like even
even
today i got a platinum with um
one of my songs
yeah yeah so you know it's just baby
steps in getting into where i want to
get to so
nice i relate to what you're saying
about not wanting to
have your youtube status detract from
your you know artist status and with me
it's uh my jackass status and then i got
into comedy you know i like just you
know this [ __ ] guy
shoves [ __ ] up his ass man you can't
just stand up
yeah yeah yeah but yeah dude give a [ __ ]
about it and it's evident that you do
too
um yeah so and i feel like i feel like
you have to work harder
than you know your normal comedians
just to really prove yourself right to
everyone essentially why do you feel
like that with rapping too
yeah yeah i feel like i have to do more
like i feel like i have to be better
than
stormzy like stormzy is the equivalent
to someone like
kendrick lamar or
[Music]
why i mean he's the biggest rapper in
the uk so i essentially
the biggest rapper in the us i i it
could be drake it could be
jay-z it could be whatever but uh
for for us like for me it's like i feel
like i need to make
better music than stormzy for people to
realize like
oh [ __ ] this ksi guy can actually do
music that's like that's
well that's the consensus man one quick
google search
and uh you know you learn right away
that your rap album is well received and
critically acclaimed
man and i think that uh having a
you know a name a profile an audience
like going in from it's a blessing and a
curse because here
like you know yeah people want to [ __ ]
on me doing comedy maybe they want to
try and [ __ ] on you doing rap
and that's the curse but at the same
time we've got a built-in audience so
we're starting with a wayhead
you know i was starting with a big
advantage well and it's also it's also
not our fault though like
you know i worked hard to
get an audience i worked hard on youtube
to create this audience
and now if i want to go into music why
is it my fault now
oh you've got a large audience you can't
do that you can't go into music but
i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want father
like if i know i've always been
interested in music i've always loved
doing music i
did music as a kid to help me remember
things in school because i had a
terrible memory
i still do and i always like write stuff
down to make sure i remember everything
that i need to do
and i'm just there like you know i like
i love making music it's a hobby it's
just
it's fun for me so just because i do
well in music
people always like to to detract um
my success and go ah just because he's
got a large fan base that's why he's
able to
you know um do well in music but it's
like
okay then why can't every musician have
a large fan base and dual music
you know it's so easy then why don't why
doesn't everyone else do it
because it's not it's not it's not easy
to build a fan base that just
you know are excited for what you put
out
it's hard to do that so yeah that's a
tommy lee said that's when you know you
start blowing up is when you have haters
so yeah like it's kind of yeah yeah for
sure and with that too like when you
have the popularity it's like you kind
of get one chance like okay you've built
an
audience so you you put out the album
people will check it out but if it's not
good
they're not going to keep coming back
and same with the stand up same with
everything
like to keep it going is a show of the
quality of the work
right and thank you paul thank you for
that because i think a lot of a lot of
people have tried to cross over into
stand-up comedy
and uh you know a lot of people kind of
fell on their ass trying that [ __ ]
but like you know when i did it i cared
about it and i
did my whole little comedy circuit and
then i kept coming back around the loop
you know and here you are with the your
new album and it's bigger and better
[ __ ] yeah go us yeah
dude